[موسيقى]
نحن أربعة أيام سيرًا على الأقدام من أقرب
طريق ، والمناظر الطبيعية الشاسعة ،
والبرية تكاد تكون غير محدودة ، ويكون الوصول إليها
بالطائرة سيرًا على الأقدام أو في اليوم المناسب ،
يمكنك ركوبها بالقارب ، لكنه يمثل تحديًا في
حد ذاته
حقًا نحن تحت رحمة
الطقس والمد والجزر وحياتنا اليومية
من الصعب العيش هنا ، ولكن
إذا فعلت ما هو مطلوب
وتجمع كل شيء معًا ، فسيكون مكانًا مجزًا حقًا
لعيش
[موسيقى]
واريك ميتشل في الوقود
وأقدم وأكبر مواطن في نيوزيلندا
الحديقة التي تغطي أكثر من 12000
كيلومتر مربع ولكنها
موطن لعشرات من
الناس فقط.  الدراجة الرباعية
لدينا قاربان للصيد
والغوص ولدينا الفريزر الذي يحافظ على
طعامنا ومنتجاتنا باردة ،
ونعتمد على مياه الأمطار لشرب المياه
حتى لا يكون ذلك صعبًا للغاية  مع سبعة أمتار
من الأمطار سنويًا ، نعيش إلى حد كبير بعيدًا
عن الأرض عندما تعيش على الأرض ،
فأنت حقًا تحت رحمة الطقس
والعوامل الجوية ، لذلك هناك
أوقات معينة تسمح لك بالخروج
وحصاد غزال أو صيد سمكة
التقط قائمة
[موسيقى]
إذا كان لديك يوم هابط وكانت الأمواج
جيدة حقًا ، فمن المرجح
أن تذهب لركوب الأمواج إذا لم تكن الأمواج
جيدة ولكن تبدو الأنهار جميلة ،
فقد تصطاد سمك السلمون المرقط إذا كانت الأمواج
مسطحة  بالنسبة للمحيطات ، فقد تذهب
لرؤية الصيد إذا كان المحيط عاصفًا ،
فقد تصعد النهر لتذهب إلى قوارب الكاياك أو تمر
عبر الأدغال لترى ما إذا كان يمكنك
اكتشاف غزال
[موسيقى]
يعيش في البرية لا يعني
أنك تعيش  بمعزل عن الأشخاص ،
لا يمكننا بالتأكيد أن نفعل ما
نفعله لولا الطيارين
وجيراننا وأصدقائنا سواء
كانت قسوة البيئة والعزلة
التي تجمع الناس
معًا أو حقيقة أن الناس
هم على استعداد للسفر هذا و  لدينا
شغف متشابه في التفكير تجاه البيئة
وفي الهواء الطلق ، هناك شيء واحد مؤكد
على مر السنين هو أن المجتمعات
أصبحت متماسكة حقًا ، هل يمكنك المضي
قدمًا وتشغيل هذا المفتاح الرئيسي
وسنرى ما إذا كانت تريد العمل أم لا.
تعرف [موسيقى] عندما تنفجر الأشياء أو لا تسير الأمور في
طريقك ، من المهم دائمًا
أن تتذكر أنك في منطقة خضراء وأن
التجارب التي تعيشها هنا وتستمتع
بالتواجد هنا ، كل شيء آخر يعد
مكافأة حتى لا تكون جادًا جدًا  إذا حدث
شيء واحد ، فأنا لا أعرف الكثير من
الأماكن في العالم حيث يمكنك الوقوف
على متن قارب بالنظر إلى الوراء ويمكنك فقط
رؤية المحيط الذي يقود إلى الغابات المؤدية
إلى الجبال الضخمة المغطاة بالثلوج في
الأنهار الجليدية على شكل خليج مع
أنهار نقية ومياه صافية  الأشجار كما
كانت قبل 200 عام والأشخاص
الذين أحضرهم هنا يمكنهم
تجربة هذه الطبيعة كما كانت
وكما ينبغي ، ونحاول الحفاظ على
المنطقة والبيئة نقية في هذه
الزاوية الصغيرة من نيوزيلندا.
[موسيقى]